come on up we're really close guys he's
getting okay it's going to be here when
I songs i am gonna say a lot of things
in America their marriage how they say
and when in Rome do with Roman too but
then they also say all roads lead to
Rome so it's just like they say hey be
Roman you're going to be there anyways
what is that thing that people want I
don't think Americans are Americans are
we going to be for soccer because we've
already seen what it does for columns
good that's art slowly its kind of
spread stem it um dating is hard right
that's kind of weird it's like I have to
got a tinder and don't get Cupid plenty
of page like that's a sort of small PR
for Michigan late
press packet Jesus somebody stretch my
dick already is this a new I got a new
phone and it came comes with this app
that pops up with a picture of my ex
with something crazy she say it's very
creative because of the conjunction app
where you can get really all that bully
loudly by someone who knows all your
juiciest secrets this is too crazy
outside come with my book it's my
messaging in my phone what else you want
to play that game with cool people but
usually playing with pairs of losers
alright that's good work I'm a good
person hi I don't like how we call
babysitting babysitting that seems kind
of cruel because kids they hate to be
called babies that's like there any word
on the kid table yeah and then see if
you sit out a child that will hurt
that'll hurt that a lot and also when
their parents all evening when they're
the most vulnerable you're kind of a
baby and random sit on them you're
insulting them i'm entering in the wood
it's kind of cool so you know so that
word is its kind of [ __ ] I'm like it
when people tell me I'm sensitive that's
[ __ ] also because they're never
saying oh you're delusional I didn't say
that they're saying no I did say that
but I didn't want you to pick up on it
[ __ ] they know who I could say an
[ __ ] they wanted man I'm not book
smart I'm street smart oh you're smart
no way that's not measurable or
comparable for you maybe you're not
smart maybe you're kind of dumb and
you're insecure about it and that's why
you punch people in the face that's not
smart that's called crying haha so I go
to jail I'll punch you in the face it
hurts are they guys keep going for your
next coming Christy letter
[Applause]